we do we do have an update here from the
associated press as well from just a few
minutes before the show started smallet
attorney says ex-empire actor will
appeal the verdict justice mullet's
defense attorney said thursday he will
appeal the former empire actor's
conviction for lying to police about the
the being the victim of a racist
anti-gay attack a jury found someone let
guilty this we now know after the vote
was read ooch told reporters simolette
was disappointed and that he's 100
percent innocent he said smollett's team
is confident he's going to be cleared of
all all accusations on all charges at a
certain point i just have to say dude
guy
give it up man
apologize
just if he had come out and said look
i was just trying to bring attention to
you know racism and i thought people
weren't listening and it was stupid i'd
have still been like screw this guy you
know what i mean but a lot of people
probably been like all right all right
he fessed up he admitted it and my
response typically is okay here's what
i'll do
if you come out admit it and apologize i
will give you a second chance you know
why
if you don't their only option is to go
the other direction so if millet does
something bad and everyone hates him for
it and then he comes out and says yo i
shouldn't have done that it was a huge
mistake i'll say all right bro i'm cool
with it i'm cool with that never do it
again and we're good because i want you
to keep walking towards the light and
away from the darkness
if you if you attack him for and say
screw you i'll never forgive you he'll
be like darkness it is and we don't want
any of that if i was working for
smoulette and i was a part of his pr
team i would have been like okay we're
bringing the bloods and the crypts
together we're bringing the trump
supporters and blm together we're going
to use this opportunity to see what we
have in common with each other and we're
going to have a sit down and we're going
to
work our differences out and actually
show that we could be civilized humane
throughout all of this and not let
political discourse ruin our humanity
that's what i would have been doing uh
but uh that's that's too that would help
too much people i think here's what
concerns me okay and this is why like i
was actually worried
that it might be you know it might be a
clean innocent verdict right because
the people that are
running black the black lives matter
organization they subscribe to a very
particular kind of ideology i mean john
mcwhorter in you know he documents this
the columbia professor and woke racism
his new book um that he sees it as a
religion right
and the idea is right that their
perspective on innocent is because of
who he is
he's innocent it doesn't actually matter
what he did right and this is this is
this is a really disturbing way to think
about the world right when you when you
when you really think about it right and
then of course other people will be
structurally innocent some people are
structurally some people are
structurally structurally guilty
and
you know you don't this is why like
you're you asked earlier you said hey
but this is this doesn't make any sense
but to people that are real believers
right in the uh the elect as john
mcwhorter calls them they actually they
think it works that way it kind of makes
me think about christianity and how like
if you accept christ into your heart you
go to heaven and if you don't you go to
hell i always never got that it's like
so it doesn't either i i just like get
i'm in the club or i'm not in the club
it doesn't matter what i do that doesn't
make any sense to me so it sounds like
black lives matter's adopted that
mentality well there's no forgiveness in
their cult as you brought up very
eloquently when you are wrong where you
when you are the person that's deemed
someone is evil someone who is
institutionally hurting people there's
no coming back from it even if you
apologize you even get attacked by them
even more and this is
apologies are in a mission of guilt so
this is the problem i don't know if
everybody agrees with me on forgiveness
but i think you have to have that
forgiveness it has to there has to be
the capability for someone to come back
to the light
they don't and that means we on the side
of forgiveness and understanding and
logic and reason are the huge's
advantage there and there's pros and
cons i suppose but they're willing to
burn it all down
let me pull up these tweets we have from
uh uh defiant l's oh yes we have joe
biden
on one on january 29th 2019 at 8 31 pm i
mean this is basically like the day the
news came out that he did this
joe biden without looking into anything
says what happened today to jesus millet
must never be tolerated in this country
we must stand up and demand that we no
longer give this hate safe harbor that
homophobia and racism have no place on
our streets and or in our hearts we are
with you jesse and then they attach this
one new york post justice molet guilty
of staging race-baiting hate attack to
boost career then we get kamala harris
she said josie smolette is one of the
kindest most gentle human beings i know
i'm praying for his quick recovery this
was an attempted modern day lynching no
one should have to fear for their life
because of their sexuality or color of
their skin we must confront this hate
and then josh kaplan jury finds actress
guilty on five counts yeah yeah we get
it so i'll say this
i would be willing to forgive some
people but
probably not jesus millet why because he
is a notorious cult leader among this
this non-theistic religion that's
probably not even fair to say it's a
cult i would not be forgiving kamala
harris or joe biden because at a certain
point it's like look
if you do something bad
and then you get caught and you fess up
and say i shouldn't have done that it
was wrong of me but i thought it was a
path to to wealth and fame and and you
know now that i got caught and it's
threatening to me i'm like i'm gonna try
and stay away from that stuff i'll be
like hey look at that that's honesty
right yeah kamala harris man how often
did she lie how about when kamala harris
tried keeping people in prison denying
them parole so she can use them as slave
labor to fight wildfires there's not a
person i'm gonna forgive because these
people are evil joe biden too her staff
is also resigning in record numbers
saying that she's scolding them to the
level where it's bringing on ptsd for
many people within her office people are
just scared of her
and there was this one tweet from this
one poor worker inside of the white
house saying hey for the record i work
for kamala and and everything's great
and it looked almost like the exact
version of that cartoon with fire all
over him saying everything is fine it
was absolutely incredible uh but but you
know these are the people that that
we're dealing with people who are
hard-headed people who believe in
themselves people who no matter what
will do anything for power and that's
exactly the game that they're in let's
be fair too are the people who are
quitting kamala harris's uh you know
administration or he would call it
because she's mean are they millennials
um is it i'm not sure they are i see
exactly the four staff members that left
because there's other complaints from
inside so it has to be a broad range it
can't just be young millennials um i i
think that would be an important factor
here because i'm wondering how much of
this is the coddling of the the american
mind is that yes you know you've got
these young people who are like kamala
came in and she was upset that i
accidentally put the wrong cream in her
coffee and kamala's like oh hey i asked
for a two cream could you get it fixed
for me and she would
and like just freaked out and i you
think i'm exaggerating too but these
people claim microaggressions are
violence and stuff like that so for all
we know kamala is doing something like
excuse me i told you to bring the packet
upstairs could you please get it done
and they freak out they're like i can't
work here
so based on the fact that she literally
kept people in prison for longer so they
could fight fires when she knew they
were innocent exactly well not not
mixing two stories i just i'll make sure
we're very careful okay yeah there were
people who were who were about to be
released on parole and her office argued
they should stay so they could be used
as slave labor there was another
individual she knew was innocent and
they tried withholding the evidence to
stop them from getting released i
believe i could be wrong about that last
one there's another fox news story that
says kamala harris staffers leaving
white house in part because they fear
being labeled harris person reporter
this is a car yeah so that's uh
other articles out there but the the
ones that i saw was
scaring people scolding them destroying
their souls uh which would make sense
from a state prosecutor that has been
absolutely ruthless throughout her
entire career and literally knowingly uh
put innocent people behind uh bars so i
think that's that you know there's still
an opportunity you know you tim you talk
about you know this opportunity for
redemption forgiveness this is an
incredibly important feature and you're
very right to say by the way that this
is absent in the
in the you know woke ideology awoke
religion but um you know perhaps they
both both the president and the vice
president can you know
seeing this very guilty verdict and say
hey look we were wrong they're not going
to do that though i mean come on
it's the weird it's the weirdest thing
that um it's not the weirdest thing it's
just it's frustrating that something can
happen with someone on the right and the
people on the right will throw them out
the window in two seconds you know um
like like if you look at what happened
with um the george floyd incident every
single person in the country immediately
jumps on board admittedly so did i i was
like that was wrong we watched it happen
it didn't look good and then later we
start getting more and more details and
we're like okay so it was kind of a bad
situation but it wasn't as cut and dry
as we as we initially thought
the left doesn't do that i mean we had
that poll yesterday from axios
that young democrats are substantially
more intolerant than young republicans
so this is this is a recurring trend
that is setting
freedom-loving individuals at a
disadvantage we're willing to forgive
we're willing to be tolerant
but the establishment liberal types
democrat types they're not
jesse smallett comes out they jump up
and they scream all to high heavens and
demand and what do conservatives do
well
not all of them but enough of them will
be like we should recognize this was bad
we'll see how it plays out
how do how how do we function if they're
willing to lie cheat and steal and then
and then i'll throw it to waukesha
when when a car an suv commits this
atrocity crazy because it gained
sentience yeah and somehow decided to
take these you know it was like
humans you know no i'm kidding
but when we get a man with black
nationalist sentiment on facebook and
support for black lives matter and he
commits this atrocity
the media drops the story overnight
yeah rest assured if there's a
conservative or right-wing person it
will be non-stop press like we had a guy
go to the ice facility we had a hundred
days of violent riding and firebombing
of a federal building in portland and
the media is like the insurrection was
january 6th
i don't i don't i don't know if it
matters to be completely honest because
i think people see through it i i think
you're right no actually i think that's
exactly that's what i was thinking i
think that's the point i think there's
all these people i mean i keep talking
to people people keep writing we get
tons of mail at epoch times uh for the
show for the whole for the whole paper
and everything and we have a ton of
people that basically say i feel
politically homeless i've heard mugged
by reality i've heard politically
homeless i've heard you know i don't
recognize you know i i i am a democrat
but what's happened right like i just i
just know i don't get what some of the
people and then and then there's this
large group of people that are just kind
of afraid to say anything because
they'll get attacked in the way that
that that conservatives tend to get
attacked right so it's it's it's
interesting like we kind of say you know
democrats or liberals but i don't i
don't i think it's not as big a group as
we think i i used to a few years ago i
actually cared and i think there's a
correlation between when cnn stopped
reporting the news and me not caring
what these people think anymore to a
certain degree so i remember i would i
would have cnn on all the time and
they'd be reporting the news and then
they'd have their stupid anti-trump
stuff but i was like you know whatever
and then one day i noticed they weren't
reporting major news it was like
protests in iran or something and so i
changed a channel and then from that
point on more and more you turn on cnn
it would be a panel about trump a panel
about trump and i was like there's no
news here and so it wasn't just this
this it wasn't this um
conscious decision where i was like cnn
has lost the plot it was kind of like
i'm looking for the news about this big
event i can't watch cnn
so at that at that point i'm getting i'm
getting to the point where i'm like
people who watch this are detached from
reality but that brought me to a point
where i was like i need to inform people
what's true and what's not true because
cnn is lying and msnbc is lying now i'm
at the point where i'm pretty sure
nobody believes them i mean
the people who do may be too far gone or
lost or whatever they're still worth
talking to and trying to communicate
with hey share this video maybe you can
you can help reach some of them but it's
it's it's funny like when i'm on twitter
and i see some of the things these
people tweet and it's just laughably
false stuff wrong wrong wrong and at a
certain point i'm like
what do you even say to someone who
believes the opposite of reality they
believe you believe the opposite of
reality but clearly we don't
i i don't know and you're not even
you're not even being hyperbolic cnn has
headlines that literally read why
inflation can actually be good for
everyday americans and bad for rich
people so when you have that level of
kind of inversion of reality of the
truth i mean there used to be a point
where i used to watch them and and i
just recognized this is extremely bad
for your mental health but they used to
be somewhat okay especially when it came
to breaking news and it wasn't that
overt but it came to a point where it's
disgusting it's like it's just like you
take nasty food and you want to throw it
up my mind is wanting to throw up every
time i put on cnn because it's it's just
so disingenuous and it's so
disrespectful for any intelligent person
that's even paying a little bit of
attention to what's going on to
understand that what they're saying is
absolutely delusional and crazy thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8 pm
and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you